what's going on ryan well i just came
back from new york they just uh they
locked the they
take comedy down from 12 o'clock to 10
o'clock and all the clubs and everything
like that
and they just uh closed up the schools
so me personally
i'm waiting for a new like 11 year old
girl maybe if there's like a greta
coveberg
that can tell us what to do because you
know we knew what to do about global
warming but then now
no well we didn't until she came along
that's what i mean they haven't ushered
in a new eleven-year-old chick that has
all the answers she's like 18
yeah looks like she's lost joe biden's
like 95
000 i'm like i'm kind of accustomed to
listen to 11 year olds nowadays
i'm conditioned it is kind of funny
though that it's like
where where are the regular aged people
like we either have little kids or we
have really old people seriously what's
up
i guess we have you know no i can you
know
there's somebody in this no i can't name
it okay
yeah all right there you go yeah and
there you go but i mean like on the left
for like their their their climate
change it's like usher bring out the
little girl
yeah it's always some little kids and
then they always have like a reactionary
right wing guy that's like i was 12 and
i actually like it
you know i i think global warming stinks
they do them
the other way yeah they i forgot the
kid's name but there was some right-wing
kid who came out like challenging
there's always sort of a yeah
an opposition crazy what is anyway
yeah you know the lockdown right now
it's crazy obviously
as soon as uh trump lost brooklyn went
nuts and it was downs are over again
it was a rave so i went there they had
like burning man trucks people were
dancing it was you know people were
crying they couldn't be happier right
and they had a people had a bag of
cheetos and they were putting them on
the floor and then stomping them
ceremonially like
that's that's cheetos because because
the orange man was dead and
they're just wasting two years at that
point it was a branded sponsor actually
yeah
you know they're very industrial cheetos
throwing out bags of people they can
stomp on them jokes aside though i do
the cheeto hour podcast if you wanna
and it's gonna be very hard to sell now
with trump so we
we're gonna need the press but dude so
they locked everything down here's a
perfect it's so crazy because
i'm watching businesses one by one drop
and like real friends of mine right
and people are still writing articles
being like these you know nazis like
here for example
there's this one comedy club that was
doing shows wrote a bunch of articles
they're trying to shut it down if you
actually talk to the guy he goes
dude i literally i'm a comedy club owner
and i have a family to feed and you know
we can't give money either like i shut
down this club go bankrupt go on welfare
or i'm trying i'm gonna try to do some
shows and try to make some money this is
where a lot of people are at and then
three places closed down and there's
nothing really anyone could do so
people try to make do and then they get
called whatever like you know murderers
and all this sort of stuff
is that is that people really calling
them murderers in new york like worse
you know worse they're calling them
racist
one worse than murderer i'll be racist
correct sir that the racist thing really
works on people
yeah no so it's it's uh but i mean
people know what to do so they and even
if they do
they have these like big leases so they
try to they try to make a little bit of
money by running a show and then people
shut it down
and that's why now i think like even
what you're talking about they're just
saying
you know what we're tired of like
tricking people remember from before for
a while they would just tell some like
you know bullcrap stuff where they go oh
i remember
all the articles that were like you know
you actually look sexy in a mask
and then they they showed a picture of
tom hardy right and he'd be like
dude in a mask looking sexy and you're
like okay well that's tom hardy
and that's that's kind of like what they
were doing and then
and then eventually they're like hey we
don't even have to lie to them anymore
we could just like tell them
to stay in their house and that'll be
the end of it and then start be raiding
and insulting them
yeah yeah that is crazy like yeah when
this all started it was like guys please
you know it's 15 days to slow the spread
we've got to work together on this and
now that it's been almost a year
they're like shut your mouth and get
back in your hovel yeah i'm done we're
done uh listening i
actually respect the people that are
kind of uh fighting the power like
there's this one comedy club they go
because you can be in synagogues right
now and they go they just announce they
go we're actually doing synagogue shows
now it's like we just want to get out
there and we
and everyone's like i see what you guys
are up to yeah but they're targeting
i know what you're thinking it'd be hard
to get paid but oh my gosh
no you do the show oh my gosh
no i'm just saying because it's illegal
i know yeah i don't know i don't know
what i was thinking
okay you're skirting around the law no
you try to get paid and you're like hey
you promised fifty dollars and they say
twenty dollars what do you need ten
dollars for
oh my god that's an old joke i know
right oh my gosh
oh joke for an old comedy show but
they're actually targeting the jewish
community pretty heavily
in uh in new york city they're going
there there's now a rumor that
cops have binoculars and they're like
trying to look through windows to see if
they can find people practicing
a religious jewish ceremony of some sort
so they can come down on them this is
i'll tell you what the craziest thing to
me is
that you could wear a cop uniform and
tell people you're doing that
yes oh these binoculars
why am i watching you shower or it's
govit reasons i'm a cop
so you know as cops we're the worst
after
old tricks we're actually at a point
where the city
government is destroying businesses by
force
specifically singling out the jewish
community so this was this this is
actually specific there's
hot spots and cuomo announces we're
going to do this lockdown
in these areas and somebody was like hey
wait a minute
those are all jewish areas and you're
ignoring the hot spots that aren't
jewish
what's up with that yeah shut your mouth
and they just they keep doing it
then they arrested one of the guys who
was leading the protests against it so
you quite literally have this is a very
funny phenomenon
the government is ordering people to
lock down in the united states across
the country and it's happening all over
europe
this is empowering massive corporations
so when the mom and pop shop shutters
amazon gets all the money
so you have this very uh uh you know
let's just call it inadvertent
lucrative merger between corporation and
states dude it's the biggest
trend of wealth in our lifetime while
while they're targeting the jews
what is that is is it does this sound
like something well i will be clear
to put a tiny wrench in that theory when
they're they're they're targeting like
the
hasidic jews in brooklyn yeah they're
not
you know that's not really like the
historically like the wealthy jews in
new york
right it's a kind of so but the issue
was when they when they announced they
were going to be locking down the hot
spots
it was like they just pointed to the
hasidic jewish neighborhood and then
ignored the hot spots outside of it
so it's like what are you what are you
doing like they went to the park and
they chained the park shut
in the jewish neighborhood yeah and a
bunch of people these these
are you pro are against this um the
lockdown absolutely no
targeting that that's i'm pointing i'm
totally against it and i'm pointing out
how crazy it is is it that we actually
have some kind of
faux pseudo-fascism and i say that
because first of all the
authoritarianism is the authoritarian
the total lockdown and stuff is
authoritarian
but like the idea that the government is
going to lock everything down
and it benefits these massive
corporations greatly to the point where
they consolidate power
it sounds very fascistic like you know
mussolini said the merge
the the merger of the corporation and
the state you know and then
you have the academic definition which
doesn't really apply but it's
fairly fascistic dude you never have to
it's so much easier to just get people
to root for what you already want them
to do
like literally right right now all these
businesses are shutting down and who's
the number one person that's for it
you know the public you know lock us in
our houses give me a bedtime get it
people are demanding put me in my pantry
and give me my ration of doughnuts
have you seen the meme where it's like
yay we defeated fascism quick
force you know now the enforced
lockdowns yeah
so and these people i've seen so many
people that are friends of mine that
they're
they're so pro this and then they kind
of go the same in the same breath they
don't have a problem with hypocrisy that
like
amazon's getting rich and all these
company countries are you know companies
are getting rich it's sort of
but you'll see this so much like i just
uh
you know there used to be like labor
parties and now they all just kind of
got woke and now they're essentially
like elitist they don't even care about
right yeah
manage managerial parties yeah hr they
are they it's you know they're like
elitist liberals they
kind of hate the working class for the
most part right oh totally yeah so
i saw them on the other day they were
making a video and they were posting on
like the you know directing sites and
stuff like that and they're like hey
we're we're
casting for this video uh we're looking
for non-union talent and non-union
directing
they're making a video about how unions
are great no for real
really wow they're casting non-union
talent and it was like
not even a speck of problem with these
like hypocrisies that they hold on their
own opinions
that's and you go well why don't you
want to hire unions you're like well
because the it's too expensive for us
and you're like but anyways back to our
steel worker video like
it's like they don't care having someone
go on camera
non-union labor to read a script about
how unions are great
it's it's absolutely insane it's
remarkable the church of scientology
hired me to do a
scientology video about the right to
marriage with my girlfriend who i wasn't
married to but
that was a weird what experience it's
just fake it's all fake
science yeah made of plastic 50 bucks
it's all it's all plastic 50 bucks
you know it's funny on a plastic there's
a video out of seattle where
a bunch of construction workers are
protesting socialists
the socialists show up to amazon and
they're protesting amazon and it's like
woke college students you know glasses
very typical colored hair and they're
like the working people and then all of
a sudden the construction workers start
shouting them down
like these people aren't the working
class they're the bourgeoisie
wearing a working-class mask trying to
convince everybody that they're you know
for
for the working class and for actual
laborers and they're the
they're they're literally this is funny
the wokeness stuff it's all hr
department
so it's quite literally it is the the
democrats have become the political
party of hr departments
managerial elites wealthy bankers the
wokeness
it's because oh no we can't have none of
that you know don't get sued
and students too like hr departments and
students
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out
and we will see you all next time
you